Khloe Kardashian has had enough for sure
the 38 year old reality star makes a
very public plea with her former
brother-in-law Kanye West on his latest
Instagram post to stop tearing down her
sister Kim I don't think there needs to
be negativity on anywhere this comes
amid the rapper's controversial Paris
Fashion Week runway show for Yeezy
season 9 which featured shirts that said
White lives matter if you're the
smartest person in the room you're in
the wrong room the shirts were heavily
slammed across social media stars like
Gigi Hadid and Venus Williams didn't
mince words I feel like I have a
responsibility to innovate and to to
fight for creativity in the wake of the
backlash yay clapped back on his page
Why did everyone feel so free to attack
me about my t-shirt but Candace Owens
was the only public figure to say that
it was wrong for the Kardashians to keep
me from seeing my daughter crazy
genuinely I cannot believe it yeah well
Kanye is referencing there an incident
in January when he allegedly wasn't
allowed to attend his and Kim's
four-year-old daughter Chicago's birth
birthday party enter Chloe who saw the
post and pleaded with the rapper in a
lengthy comment quote please stop
tearing Kimberly down and using our
family when you want to deflect again
with the birthday narrative enough
already we all know the truth and in my
opinion everyone's tired of it own
whatever it is Chloe tells Kanye her
message comes from a place of love she
says she didn't want to Hash it out
publicly on social media but
acknowledges you keep bringing it here
it's also not what you say it's how you
say it Sheen's a comment begging yay to
leave Kim and the kids out of it so they
can be raised peacefully always remember
to be kind and
just courteous of what's happening
around you too of course it didn't take
long for yay to respond in a separate
post he shared Chloe's entire comment
and his side of the story in the caption
quote you are lying and are liars y'all
basically kidnapped Chicago on her
birthday so she could remember her
father not being there that's how y'all
play with black fathers I'm just
extremely happy can you tell by my face
but Coco's not alone her younger sister
Kendall Jenner also showed where her
loyalty lies it's kind of as simple as
that her pal Jaden Smith attended the
easy show but left early after seeing
the offensive t-shirts following his
exit he tweeted I had to dip LOL I don't
care who it is if I don't feel the
message I'm out black lives matter
Kendall liked all three of the tweets a
subtle and simple way of showing her
support
[Music]
foreign